hi Matt here I am super excited to
introduce you to our faster
smarter.io Resource page we have
compiled some quick tip videos our
newsletter and my new book think faster
talk Smarter on one page all of this is
designed to help you to continue honing
your communication check out faster
smarter dot IO
to truly hone and develop your
communication you have to introspect
reflect seek feedback and integrate all
of that information to improve
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast
today I am super excited to chat with
Celine Teo Celine is a facilitator of
the gsb's famous interpersonal Dynamics
course she's a CEO coach and a GSB
graduate welcome Celine I so look
forward to our conversation I'm looking
forward to this as well Matt I'm excited
excellent well let's go ahead and get
started I'd like to start with the
interpersonal Dynamics course that you
help facilitate it's also known as
touchy-feely and you and others help run
that course can you remind our listeners
what the course is about how it works
and and share maybe two key takeaways
from it of course interpersonal Dynamics
is the most popular elective at the
Stanford GSB it's really about teaching
people how to be effective interpersonal
communicators and how to do so both at
work as well as in their personal lives
how it works well one example I can
bring to you is when I was a student an
MBA at the GSB one exercise that we ran
in Tachi Philly is notorious it's known
as the influence line where other
students have to rank you according to
how influential you are to them and
consistently I wound up in the bottom
half of everyone's influence line and I
was devastated here I was a new
immigrant to the United States female
Asian
and I couldn't understand why I was at
the bottom of the influence line so I
felt
sad I felt disappointed in myself I felt
hard done by resentful and normally what
I would do would be to disengage and say
you know what you don't think I'm
influential I'm stepping out but what's
great about this course is it encourages
you to re-engage and so I dug into the
feedback
got insights from other people as to why
I was coming across that way and as a
result changed the way I behave when I'm
in American contexts
what's great about that is that I
Diversified the range of behaviors that
I bring to bear so when I'm in the
states I come across with a little bit
more emotion and more animation and when
I'm in Asia I can come across with like
less amplitude and I have this range of
behaviors now I can pick and choose from
and I have agency
so that's what interpersonal Dynamics
does it's a phenomenal course and one of
the strengths I think of the course is
that it really helps people as you
shared in your story to really learn
about themselves and to learn about
themselves in a very direct way not mean
but to learn about themselves and then
as you said to develop a sense of agency
to make those changes that are needed
and thank you for sharing that in all of
our interactions you are certainly
influential in my book you would be at
the top of my line so thank you for that
thank you Matt I'd love for you to share
how all of us can be a little bit more
touchy-feely if you will when we work in
organizations or corporate cultures that
emphasize the logic and action what can
we do to be more empathetic and
connected to those environments
one of the things I will say is I'll
repeat advice that David Bradford one of
the key developers of the Tachi Philly
course told me when I was actually chair
of the Stanford alumni Consulting team I
asked him David how do you bring Tachi
Philly to organizations and he said
stealth it in with a check-in and this
is how you do it you go around the room
in any meeting and everybody says one
feeling word how are you feeling today
and one sentence as to why the reason
why you do that is because it creates
the space for someone to say here's
what's going on with me outside work now
what happens is you no longer have the
sales team talking to the marketing team
no you have a parent talking to another
parent or you have a caregiver talking
to another caregiver you have more hooks
more chances for people to connect with
each other
when I do my work as a CEO coach with
startups a lot of the CEOs tell me
Celine that'll take too long but
honestly
five minutes I guarantee you five
minutes is all it takes and then on top
of that many of them will tell me Celine
I can't say the word feelings in my
organization where a bunch of coders
that word is not okay
and what I tell them is okay don't say
feelings instead use a prompt like what
was one good thing that happened to you
today
what was one bad thing that happened to
you today what's keeping you up at night
and then over time you can slowly slowly
increase the vulnerability and the range
of emotions that you're allowing people
to bring in
I love the advice and thank you again
for the specific examples about how we
can start with something as simple as
just Begin by by checking in with each
other and in fact doing so can warm
people up and and get the conversation
going and it doesn't always have to be
about an emotion and and I loved what
you said about how it changes our
relationship so I'm no longer my
functional role talking to your
functional role where two people
communicating and that immediacy and
connection I can see brings a lot of
value are there other bits of advice
that you have or experiences you have as
a facilitator of interpersonal Dynamics
or in your own private practice that can
really help connect people together are
the things we can do or say that can
help with that
I think there are two things I would
recommend one is is to be very clear
about what you're feeling because
feelings are data and in the rest of our
logical lives we would never make
decisions on bad or highly abstract data
but we'll do that with feelings we'll
just say I'm feeling sad mad or glad but
that's not detailed enough so what I
like to recommend is for people to
actually take a page from Carol Robin's
book connect in the back of that
appendix you'll actually see a feelings
chart carry that feelings chart around
and check in at the beginning of
meetings at the end of meetings and say
how am I feeling right now at a granular
level as an example before our chat
today I've listened to this podcast
since the very beginning I love it
and so as a result before I came in
today I was excited I was glad I was
anticipatory but I was also nervous
and so what did I do with that I decided
I would go for a walk get some of those
nerves out I would practice my vocal
exercises and then I decided to reframe
you and I will have a wonderful
conversation and I think it makes for
just a much more fun interaction than if
I were just I'm just nervous uh
absolutely so certainly no need to be
nervous here and I too was very much
looking forward to this so again I hear
the advice much like you give to our
students is you really have to reflect
on yourself where you're at and and take
that as information and put in data from
which you can then act and I think
you're exactly right a flex in thinking
about my own life when I look at my
emotional state I'll just label it I
won't actually go much deeper and I
think that's really important because
then you can take action if I just say
I'm nervous but if I think more about
that nervousness and how I can address
it then I can do something about it so I
like how the reflection leads to data
that can lead to action exactly very
helpful very helpful
I love to get your thoughts and advice
on how do you manage challenges and
issues and disagreement at work when
you're confrontational rather than
collaborative
I would say it's all about empathy okay
conflict is magnetic it draws attention
and whenever we encounter conflict our
attention tends to go to this narrow
Focus point that is the conflict alone I
like to encourage my clients to expand
their perspective and think about the
relationship as a whole as a container
and then go to gottman's research
that we also reference in interpersonal
Dynamics godman found out that there's a
five to one magic ratio of positive
interactions to negative interactions in
successful relationships so my advice is
build your emotional piggy bank by
depositing those five good interactions
in before you have the conflict
built that and then even in the conflict
continue depositing those positive
interactions in as a way of making sure
that your conflicts go well because
you're demonstrating good intent you're
demonstrating that the relationship is
important to you and these positive
interactions can be really small they
could be a smile and I meet they could
be a pat on the shoulder they could be a
knot of the head it's easy but we forget
I forget
yes I certainly am familiar with
gottman's work and this notion of
storing up
positive interaction and and I see this
in my interactions with my kids there's
a lot that I try to actively acknowledge
the successes as a parent it can be very
easy to focus on the the things you'd
like to change or advice you'd like to
give so it I consciously try when
positive accolades or appraiser are
appropriate to give that knowing not
only that will help in the moment but it
might help me in those times where I
have to give negative feedback or have a
conflictual situation that's huge Matt I
love that you're doing this with uh your
family and even at work we have slack
channels called celebration where people
are encouraged to drop in and just
celebrate somebody else for something
they did or at the end of meetings we'll
actually have breakout rooms where we'll
put two people in together and celebrate
each other and that's really fabulous
how that can help people and I begin to
think back to when you talked about ways
to bring empathy and feeling into
organizations with a check-in at the
beginning
some kind of gratitude or celebration at
the ending might be a really nice way to
to round out an interaction or meeting
they're nice bookends that's right
that's perfect for those of our
listeners who are looking to enhance or
hone their empathy feedback and
communication skills what advice and
guidance would you give them based on
your experience
I would recommend
asking so
the reason why I say that is all of us
here sitting in Silicon Valley business
types we tend to have advice monsters we
like to give advice
and what I would encourage people to do
instead is to ask
do you need support or advice right now
and you'd be surprised the number of
times people say I actually know what I
need to do I don't need your advice I
just want someone to commiserate with me
so do that ask first we assume people
need advice but that's not necessarily
always the case and the support
component gives us a chance to connect
with the other person yeah totally get
it my wife and I have a lot of
conversations around this issue as a
professor as somebody giving advice is
something that I do as a reflex and and
listening and understanding if support
is needed is really important I actually
think and this is a little bit true for
myself that giving advice is a way to
hide
behind you hide behind the advice so you
don't actually have to connect and
engage and I'm wondering if you find
that to be true and have any advice on
how to have that confidence to be
vulnerable to I'm here to support you
but I don't quite know how to do that or
what's needed in the moment it's much
easier for me to say oh just go do this
yes of
really agree with you on that and also
say that advice giving is distancing
because it puts us in a position of
superiority it assumes that we know the
answer and hey Matt I can fix you just
do this
you know it's distancing and so my
recommendation is actually to tiptoe
into it by sometimes even just knowing
that phrase do you want support or
advice right now
just practicing that because once you
can say that the response your response
depends on what the other person says
and they will guide you as to what they
need so just ask
I think putting yourself in a place
where you can just be receptive is hard
but very useful and have seen that play
out very successfully many times in my
life so thank you for that
so Celine before we end I'd like to ask
you the same three questions I ask
everyone who joins me are you up for
that yes all right excellent so question
number one if you were to capture the
best communication advice you have ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would it
be
it would be people will remember how you
made them feel that's by Maya Angelou
absolutely tell me more about why that's
so important for you
it's not about the words
it's about how people feel inside that's
how you persuade that's how you connect
that's that's who we are we're emotional
beings I think that's exactly right and
we need to think about how we we impact
people on an emotional level
I think we do a disservice when we think
about our communication is only
information transfer it is clearly a
motion transfer as well and we need to
bring those two into balance and that
quote is is very helpful to remind us of
that I love that phrase emotional
transfer well there you go
question number two who is a
communicator that you admire and why I
think Steve Jobs comes to mind you know
he used passion Simplicity storytelling
to be memorable and so much emotion
absolutely and the thing I like about
Steve Jobs in terms of his communication
is he worked really hard on it you know
he was very good at it had lots of
natural talent but he worked hard
tirelessly to improve and hone and and
he also made sure to focus the message
in a very concise clear audience-centric
way so I agree lots of good things to
learn there so much hard work
underpinning what looked effortless
isn't that amazing how how and I think
that's a great lesson for all of us to
remember is that practice in preparation
can make things easier and look easier
question number three what are the first
three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe
I think listening to understand
finding commonality and connecting
through feelings
so connecting through feelings I I see
absolutely from what we've talked about
talk to me about listening to understand
I think that's bound up with empathy
right you can't really communicate if
you don't understand what it is your
audience is looking for your counterpart
is looking for what they care about
we focus too much on ourselves
yeah and I feel like people and myself
included when I listen I'm listening for
the hooks that give me what I want to
say next or help me get to the next
place and not necessarily reflecting on
what this means for the other person and
potentially for this relationship
interaction Etc so I like that idea of
listening to understand yeah it's all
it's part it ties back to what you said
about practice conceptually it's an easy
concept but it's really hard to do
because you have to let go so much of
your own agenda yeah you have to quiet
your mind and really be present and for
a lot of us that's hard Celine thank you
so much this was a true pleasure to chat
with you this notion of really
respecting our feelings and embracing
them and looking at ways to really
understand ourselves so that we can
bring our more whole self and emotional
self to our interactions our
communication is absolutely important so
thank you for the lessons thank you for
your time and and thank you for sharing
important information with all of us
thank you Matt pleasure was all mine
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Ryan Campos and me Matt
Abrahams our music was provided by Floyd
Wonder for more information and episodes
find us on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcasts thank you and please make
sure to subscribe and follow us on
LinkedIn